hey what is up guys mkbhd here we are
back and this
is google
glass now something that a lot of people
ask when you know you go out and walk
around with this thing on your face a
lot of people ask the same set of
questions one
what is glass what is that thing on your
face two what does it do and three what
does it look like while you're wearing
it what do you see through glass so
without any further ado let's go ahead
and take a look
first of all this here this exact model
that we're looking at is the explorer
edition of google glass that's a bit
more important than a lot of people
realize basically this is not the final
version of the product there will be an
evolution in software and hardware
before an actual consumer edition is
created in fact there's been several
software updates already but for now the
explorer edition is a limited edition
early version for people willing to go
out and explore and give feedback for
google about glass aesthetically it's a
pretty interesting little device because
it sits on your face like a regular pair
of glasses
but well there are no actual lenses
there's no glass in google glass except
for this prism here and the other thing
about it that's different is it's
asymmetrical so typically when you're
wearing glasses there's the same thing
on both sides with glass all the
smartphone components and all the things
in google glass that make it what it is
are all on your right hand side now
while glass does have mostly smartphone
insides what it doesn't have is a
cellular radio which means it can't
connect to data by itself so what it
does do is connect to either wi-fi or
bluetooth tethering to your smartphone
and connect to the my glass app on your
android or ios device and that's very
important because without it you
wouldn't be able to do anything on glass
unless you had a device with you
connected to it so this is really what's
going to power glass and make it do all
that it does when it connects to the
internet and pulls any sort of data so
how does it actually look to be looking
through the actual prism in google glass
well google says that it's supposed to
look approximately like a 25-inch
display from 8 feet away so if you have
a 25 inch computer monitor back up your
chair roll back 8 feet away and that's
about what it'll look like now it's
obviously not an hd display in fact it's
around 640 by 360. but the idea here is
that this is all that you look at when
you interface with google glass so it's
pretty important essentially it's a
square that is fixed in the upper right
side of your vision it's not in the
corner it's not totally crazy like hard
to reach stretch with your eye as bad
but it's definitely out of the way so
it's not going to be intruding your
vision all the time so looking through
the prism it'll look about like that
that's about right so when wearing glass
natively glass by itself can do
seven things with it you can do seven
things you can take a picture record a
video
navigate somewhere send a message
call someone
hangouts
and google let's not forget that this is
the like we said the explorer edition of
google glass not the final consumer
version so the list of things that it
can do is limited but the idea here is
that this is a new form factor this is
the beginning of a new sort of paradigm
we have android phones that's one form
factor we have android tablets that's
another form factor we'll have a whole
bunch of smart watches soon that's
another form factor glass which is a
wearable tech on your face is a totally
different form factor so think of this
as sort of like an android phone with no
apps on it out of the box it can do you
know a sort of core set of functions and
that's normal for an android phone
that's a small list of things it can do
out of the box but once you add an app
store once you add the connectivity that
a whole bunch of developers and a
developer army kind of support that list
of things is going to get a lot longer
and a lot more interesting there are a
few officially supported third party
apps right now for glass you know
twitter facebook there's a new york
times app for sort of pop-up news alerts
but in the glass explorer community
there's a whole bunch of developers
doing their thing and making a ton of
different apps for glass and of course
when there's a final release where
pretty much anyone can develop for it
and anyone can buy it that sort of
mainstream apps are kind of a no-brainer
expect to see a youtube app an instagram
app these kind of things are pretty much
undoubtedly going to come to glass when
it's finally available for everyone but
back to those seven things those seven
functions of google glass are really not
all that different from the core
functions of an android phone without
any apps installed if you bought a nexus
4 and never used anything in the play
store you'd get a pretty similar list of
things that you can do with it out of
the box but again like we said this is
the explorer edition many more things
are going to be added now for a brief
rundown of these seven okay i'm going to
go through all seven of these things
first of all all these things are going
to be done with an interaction with the
trackpad on the side of glass so there's
a swipe forward backward down and a tap
and this actually feels pretty natural
with the sort of light tapping you're
not really bashing it against your own
head but you're just doing slight slip
swipes and light taps and things like
that and that feels normal number one
you can take pictures so you can say
okay glass take a picture or if you
don't want to do that at all you can
just tap that photo button that's on the
top of glass and i just took a picture
of you the camera and the light so
that's what you look like right now
and if i want to take a video that's the
next function of glass of course you can
say ok glass record a video and you'll
start recording a video or you can
actually hold down the photo button on
the top of glass and you automatically
start taking a 10 second video so you're
going to start looking at what i'm
seeing which is basically a bunch of
lights and a microphone but uh yeah
that's what it looks like to take a
video with glass it's automatically
going to take a 10 second video so if
you want to extend it you have to tap
the photo button again and you'll get
like an unlimited recording time until
like the battery dies until you stop
recording the photo and video quality
are really pretty good and this is one
of the defining features of what makes
glass so special because it's basically
a first person look at what someone's
actually doing now it's a little bit
above your field of vision so if you're
like handheld gaming or something like
that you kind of have to look down a
little bit to get it in your field of
view i found the most part though most
of the things that i do with glass are
pretty amazing and you would never be
able to get any sort of camera angle
like that uh doing anything else
especially because you have both your
hands free which is cool
the video quality is also really good
because it's such a wide angle lens it
uses very similar optics that the galaxy
nexus did but that doesn't stop it from
being uh really quite good and also the
photos that i took again from that first
person view were really good because it
takes a burst of i think 10 different
shots of a bunch of different exposures
and gets a really nice high dynamic
range shot and again that combined with
the wide angle makes it look a lot like
what you would see
out of the human eye so it's really
really close to first person view of
what regular people look at so the third
thing glass does is walking directions
driving it's just navigation with google
maps so you can say okay glass get
directions to
and then say wherever you want to go b h
for example and it'll give you the
directions and an actual real-time arrow
where you would be going on glass with
you know the directions to where you're
going you can do walking navigation
biking navigation and driving navigation
and i think this is actually probably
the most awesome of the built-in
features in class because if you're in
an unfamiliar place and you don't really
know where you're going you move your
head around you get to see the exact
direction of the orientation of the
arrow change and you can just literally
follow the arrow in glass to get where
you're going and that's really powerful
stuff now four on five you can send a
message or place a call using glass and
that's because it's tethered to your
phone with the myglass app so you have a
certain list of your starred contacts
that you can dial whenever you want so
you can say okay glass send a message to
john i'll be late i'm in traffic see you
in 20 minutes or ok glass call john and
it'll start calling that person so you
have to have that person start already
in order to make a call to them
otherwise it would be kind of crazy to
search through your whole android
contacts library but that's pretty cool
hands-free you could be you know totally
you know busy with your hands and not
have any sort of control over your
smartphone and still place a call cell
under send a message if it's important
and number six last but definitely not
least is the google search and google
now now you guys already know how google
search works so i can say okay glass
google
how long is the golden gate bridge
and you guys already know basically how
google search works but it'll read the
answer back to me the golden gate bridge
is
8980 feet
uh 2737 meters if that matters to you so
you already know how that works and it
works the same way that it does with
google now on your phone but google now
on your phone also gives you sort of
predictive search results and gives you
relative
relevant information wherever you go
glass will do the same thing so you can
swipe through the glass interface and
view all this information where you'll
need to know you know either whether
where you are some uh translation data
if you're in a different country all
kinds of different crazy things
the same way google now on your phone
would do but the bottom line with the
glass explorer edition is this this is
not the final version this is not where
you're going to be able to buy in a few
weeks or months when there's a final
version available the final version is
going to have updated hardware is going
to have updated software and it's going
to have an updated price because right
now the explorer edition costs fifteen
hundred dollars in the united states for
all glass explorers hopefully it'll be
nowhere near fifteen hundred dollars
when it's finally mass produced it'll
hopefully be uh way less than half of
that but go ahead and leave what you
would pay for google glass like this in
the comments section below that like
button i feel like a lot of people would
probably max out at around 500
maybe less maybe 400 or 300 but we don't
know what the price is going to be but
this is a google glass explorer edition
i'll have more videos on this to come i
have a lot more content that i want to
show you guys
regarding glass and a whole bunch of
other tech stuff but if you enjoyed this
one definitely feel free to give a
thumbs up below and be sure to subscribe
to see more glass coverage and more tech
videos like this thank you for watching
and i'll talk to you guys in the next
one
peace
you